so I have a really interesting video for
you today as I'm gonna show you
something that very very few people have
ever seen or heard of before at least
not yet in fact I'm gonna show you four
photos that were sent to me of something
that was recently discovered at a
notable ancient Egyptian site which for
some reason is yet to be shared with the
public or make the headlines now the
discovery in itself is fascinating but
the implications of not only what it is
but specifically where it is may make
your jaw drop and of course later in
this video I will be sharing the big
awkward reason why this hasn't been
shared with the public or made the
headlines and trust me when I say that
you're gonna find that reason disturbing
now let me start off by sharing where
these four photos were taken which just
so happens to be at a notable ancient
Egyptian site known as the dendara
complex this site is known for a few
highly recognizable features including
the massive stone columns that make up
the temple of hot or and also be
incredibly interesting and of course
highly debated hieroglyphs and
petroglyphs found throughout this site
but what if there was something else
here that was hidden from everyone
Egyptologists archeologists researchers
something really big and although you
couldn't say that it was hiding in plain
sight but what if it was something right
under our noses that's nobody ever
thought to go looking for now what do I
mean by under our noses well like I
mentioned a moment ago this is the
temple of hot or famous for the
incredibly large columns and impressive
stonework that cover virtually every
inch of every wall column and ceiling
throughout the temple in fact there are
dozens of columns 24 in total between
two hall rooms all of which are 15
meters are nearly 50 feet tall and the
24 does not include the outside columns
that surround the temple the decorative
work is astounding and full of
incredible symbolism a trove of
knowledge that was community
hated and passed down by the ancient
Egyptians thousands of years ago now hot
or was Mother of the Sun God raw and sky
god Horus look at the face of hot or and
the late Egyptologist John Anthony West
described her interesting and unusual
appearance as a form of symbolism for
example her triangular face may have
represented the shape of a uterus
essentially depicting her as the Divine
Feminine also noticed the ears those are
certainly not human ears and many
including John Anthony West stated that
they are cow ears but why would those
have been chosen
what symbolism are those meant to
represent different people have
different thoughts on this but one thing
is for sure the appearance and shape of
hot taurus face is much different than
any depiction of any females face
depicted by the ancient Egyptians and
also notice how all of them are defaced
it is not known who did this when or for
what reasons but in many ways this giant
temple which is literally a building
made entirely of stone could be
considered a planetarium of sorts that
hot or represents the cosmic mother the
mistress of time astronomical cycles and
all cycles of time and it's worth
mentioning that this temple represents
the time of the Old Kingdom when Egypt
was led by many priestesses and was a
matriarch for a period of time as well
something few people seem to discuss
which I find interesting
now the ceiling itself ties into the
astronomical cycles I just mentioned and
in many details for example what you see
here is said to represent the waxing of
the moon which totals 28 days
so you see 14 gods and goddesses on 14
stairs said to represent the 28 total
days that make up the full and new moon
cycles another example of the cosmos
being represented in this temple
includes what is referred to as the
Dendera zodiac which the Egyptians
likely took straight from the ancient
Sumerians 6,000 years ago and made it
their own there are many other
fascinating details about what is
inscribed on the stone throughout this
temple but that is not what this video
is about however I want
share with you the nature of this temple
that incredible intelligence went into
not only constructing it which in itself
is impressive but the thousands of years
of learned knowledge that would have
went into developing the information
shared within the temple is simply
incredible but like I said at the
beginning of this video what if there
was something else here something that
was hidden from everyone and for
thousands of years and by the way if
you're not aware I recently started an
Instagram account a few months ago where
I'm sharing more details about this
channel including clues about my
upcoming videos as well as I intend to
share more information about my personal
life so you can get to know me a bit
better but I was very fortunate that an
awesome friend named Jaime reached out
to me through Instagram having recently
returned home from a life-changing trip
to visit ancient Egyptian sites back in
April she had an opportunity to see many
things that others traveling in large
tour groups normally do not as she
traveled with just a few people and
hired an experienced Egyptian tour guide
a tour guide who had many insider
connections with various guards and
Egyptian officials and was able to gain
access to certain locked doors in
exchange for of course cash money
so while visiting the temple of hot or
Jaime was fortunate enough to see
something that was recently uncovered on
the floor of this very temple again
something that only a small number of
people have seen or been made aware of
so without further ado this is what she
was shown what you're looking at here
which is seen with the removal of this
large and very heavy floor stone is not
a round stone paver in fact it is the
very top of a buried upright stone
column which appears to be of not just
one column but multiple uprights and
buried columns which is directly
underneath the temple of hot or that's
right directly beneath all of this is
another temple full of columns I did not
know how many columns there are how tall
or wide they are or how widespread the
below temple is but Wow please leave a
comment thinking Jaime for these
outstanding phone
and give this video a thumbs up if
you've never seen or heard of this
discovery before let's get the word out
but really you would expect to have
heard about this discovery from I don't
know
multinational news outlets the National
Geographic or maybe just maybe the
Egyptian antiquities department which of
course oversees all of these sites now
take a look at this diagram which shows
you the specific location within the
temple that has this missing floor stone
and the multiple buried columns but
speaking of this missing floor stone
which was only removed in the first
place in order to conduct restorations
on it which was apparently within just
the last few months and this is of
course how they came to discover these
columns in the first place and by the
way is this actually multiple buried
columns or is this just one massive one
with unique shape I mean real quick
compared to the shape of the columns
that we do see inside this temple and
notice the similarity I'm not exactly
sure what to make of this and I'm
curious to know what your thoughts are
in the comments but the question becomes
how tall are these buried columns how
many are there how big is the Buried
temple down below and what is waiting to
be discovered inside of it so let's get
this straight the already incredible
side of hot tour which contains a wealth
of information about our ancient past
just so happens to be sitting on top of
a long lost buried temple and nobody
knows what's waiting to be discovered in
it and the people running the show
haven't made the public aware of it yet
hmm so this is the part involving why
you haven't heard about this fascinating
and by the way significantly important
discovery yet the private guide informed
Jamie that they will be covering it back
up and will wait to excavate it once
they can do so in secret those were his
exact words that's right the guide
himself said that they will conceal it
and we'll be excavating it without the
public's knowledge at an unknown time in
the future which I assume means that the
wait until more broad restorations are
required at the site when they can lock
it down for extended periods of time
these photos literally prove that the
authorities overseeing these ancient
sites are actively preventing newfound
information from reaching the masses
think about that this info isn't being
shared with professors archaeologists
Egyptologists or researchers the people
with control over these sites have
reason to do the things that they do on
their own
in secret before sharing whatever they
decide to share with the public
am i the only one that sees a major
issue with this and and by the way of
all places that this very temple happens
to be at is a site where some of the
most debated stone reliefs from anywhere
in ancient times exists such as that
which is commonly referred to as the
dendara light bulb look at this thing
and tell me it doesn't make your eyebrow
go up now I've done quite a bit of
research on this and read and listen to
many different perspectives from both
the mainstream academic explanation to
those who suggest that this is evidence
of ancient technology now the academic
perspective on this is that the lotus
flower depicts the god horus emerging
from the blooming flower at the
beginning of the day and the energy of
horus is represented by the snake now
that part about the snake supposedly
depicting Horus would seem like a
stretch but also keep in mind that the
stone facing this one shows Horus and
the snake together which is why they say
the snake in this picture represents
Horus assuming you buy into that now the
bulb part of it is said to depict the
sanctuary of the Sun or rather the
birthplace of our Sun perhaps symbolism
of our atmosphere that protects us the
supporting Jade pillars below are
following the sky on its nightly journey
and the people below are said to be
celebrating the new Sun as the journeys
across the new sky essentially being
born which is why many believe this
represents the story of creation now I
have a few thoughts of my own on this
and I must say that the explanations of
that this is symbolic of essentially
creation is actually highly compelling
based on other examples of symbolism at
hot tours temple I highly recommend you
research this on your own and develop
your own conclusions but it seems to me
that this is probably not a light bulb
but I also think that
this may well represent great knowledge
and perhaps of the use of this knowledge
in the form of energy hear me out as
there's a few details that many people
who are convinced that this thing is
strictly symbolic and has absolutely
nothing to do with technology seem to
overlook let's look to the right of this
the hieroglyphs themselves give warning
but the question is warning to what now
look at this figure which almost looks
like the body of a baboon except the
tail is much different than that of a
baboon and the face seems to look like I
don't know a toad or a frog of some kind
this is beyond unusual and get this this
is literally the only place throughout
anywhere in ancient Egypt that this
being whoever it is has been found this
is the one and only example interesting
and I I do like the points made by
authors Brian Forrester and Stephen
mailer and the explanation of this in
that look at how it's holding two knives
could this be symbolic that this
knowledge could be used for good or bad
that it could be used to improve life or
harm you because after all that is
certainly an accurate way of describing
electricity it can cook your dinner heat
your house or electrocute you to death
it has to be mentioned that the
depictions of snakes literally represent
energy and most all ancient
civilizations including Kundalini energy
now I'm not saying that this is
necessarily depicts electricity at all
and again I doubt that its light bulb
even though it surely looks like a light
bulb but whether it is or isn't is it
really that out of the realm of
possibilities that we don't fully
understand the meaning or the context of
this I mean any honest and informed
researcher would say yes to that as even
in modern times you can't report on any
story without people coming to totally
different conclusions but not only that
many people that identify with the
mainstream academic narrative of its
symbolism all seem to have different
differing nuanced versions of it it's
actually a bit inconsistent which is odd
for people claiming to know exactly what
it is now
many see this and consider that the
lotus flower seems to be connected by a
cord to the box
below on the right guys again research
this on your own there are many logical
explanations that have nothing to do
with technology but if there was one
point I would make about all of this
besides that there is a warning given on
the rights of this depiction which
doesn't seem to belong there with the
story and symbolism of creation I mean
really why is there a warning for this
clearly there's more to interpret in the
details here that most seem to overlook
but I do have specific questions as to
what's referred to as the JED the JED is
supposed to symbolize stability but more
specifically it is said to represent the
spinal cord of the god Osiris although I
can understand it's symbolizing
stability in certain examples there are
other examples that tell me it's
something far more specific I mean just
look at this and tell me how you could
conclude that this represents the god
Osiris is spinal cord plus if you look
closely it's almost like a two pronged
fork at the top this is something very
unique and I questioned it's true
meaning in certain examples and there
are many other interesting depictions of
this but it's examples like this that
suggests that we don't fully understand
the meaning and context and by the way
as far as stability goes pillars and
columns certainly provide stability
which is what this looks like it looks
like an oddly shaped pillar but what's
particularly interesting is that this is
literally nothing like any other
Egyptian made column or pillar ever
found they just don't look like this at
all the JED interpretation came from an
English man named Wallace budge a
hundred years ago who is notable for
translating the Egyptian Book of the
Dead budge stated that originally Osiris
was probably represented by the JED
alone and that he had no other form just
this pillar thing he regards the JED
hieroglyph as a conventional
representation of a part of his spinal
column and gives its meaning as quote to
be stable to be permanent abiding
established firmly enduring I have to
say that I think that there's more to
that story than just that leave a
comment and share what your thoughts are
on all of that but one thing that I'm
very curious about is this
they're highly unusual stone relief that
is right next to this light bulb I mean
just look at it those unique faces with
the cow ears what exactly is connected
to their head I mean honestly this is
some weird stuff and I sense that it's
true meaning goes far beyond the
explanation that this half circular
thing at the bottom is a manaat'
necklace which well yes it is but what
is the meaning of this necklace and what
is its place in this particular
stonework why is it connected to
multiple strange-looking heads meaning
and contexts are beyond significant and
here we are now thousands of years later
trying to interpret what they were
trying to tell us so it's more than
reasonable to say that we probably are
mixing some accurate as well as some
inaccurate information and coming to
conclusions
I mean my ultimate conclusion is that we
don't ultimately fully understand the
meaning of it and it's foolish for
anyone to say that they have it 100%
figured out what I know is that I don't
know but this is a fun conversation
regardless of what you think it is
because here we are we're discussing it
and it's not being forgotten
and as well it's being brought to new
eyes that have never seen or heard of
this before which by the way I mean this
whole site in itself the Dinaric complex
and these incredibly interesting
hieroglyphs as well as the temple of hot
tour and those massive columns most
people have never even seen or heard of
this stuff before as it's simply not
included in most curriculum for ancient
studies I mean they teach you about the
Sphinx and the pyramids and mummies and
King Tut right but have you seen about
this when you were in school I mean have
you ever seen these things before I know
I wasn't taught about this stuff but all
of that said here we are now with the
knowledge that there is a completely
hidden temple just waiting to be
discovered at this very site who knows
what is buried down there or engraved on
the stone walls within it and for a site
that is already so impressive and
debatable the fact that this recent
discovery is being kept from the masses
really makes you think again a special
thank you to my friend Jamie for sending
me these outstanding photos but you will
all be thrilled to hear that there are
other photos that she sent me that are
behind closed and locked doors and gates
at various Egyptian sites and it is
truly interesting
what they don't want everyone to see on
these tour groups so look forward to an
excellent video with those photos soon
so to close all this up despite all the
disagreements between various academic
researchers or so called fringe
researchers or even those that think
that aliens built the pyramids the one
thing that we all have in common is the
fact that we have all been left in the
dark about this discovery assignment
every one that shares the unique passion
for our ancient history to unite and
come together and realize that hey we're
not being fed the whole story and if
there's one thing that we all have in
common is that we want to know what the
truth is right and without a doubt all
of us want to know what the story is of
these buried columns why were they
buried in the first place and what is
waiting to be seen down below anyways
guys I'm gonna wrap it up here but leave
a comments let me know what your
thoughts are on all of this hit the like
button and subscribe if you haven't and
of course follow me on Instagram if you
haven't done that already but I'll leave
it there look forward to a great video
coming soon but yeah I'm Jimmy this is
bright insight take care everybody